did you take acting lessons growing up I
went to I went to well I went to High
School of Performing Arts right and so
there was an acting class do you have to
audition again yes was your audition
could you remember the audition vividly
what did you do you have to sign in
Sydney Bernstein's window I did a
monologue from and then I did a
Shakespeare monologue from Taming of the
Shrew Shakespeare ugh
not why not my thing because amateur not
my thing because to me I would think
just memorize are you do you have an
incredible memory
sometimes yes sort of so I would you
know and for it depends on what it is
right I I I I you know friends was
pretty but I would think on Friends
getting a new script every week and they
change the script all the time right I
mean they're looking for jokes they're
looking so they have to keep changing it
as you rehearse during the week right
yeah and then you have to keep going
with that and memorizing this thing and
you're doing it in front of a live
audience well no there's only one night
a week that you're doing it in front of
the audience I would Panic well there
was especially if you get a monologue
and they say okay we've Rewritten it I
mean there was scribble all over that
set how do I remember my lines I mean I
write it on the table and you just peek
down at it every once in a while oh is
that what you did we would it was sort
of everywhere that's allowed if we edit
well I don't know but we did it talk to
me about this because I think in a way
this is a really interesting thing and I
don't even know that I have it right
okay but like when you first decide to
go to LA to become an actress right
that's the move you decide hey if I'm
gonna make it I tried in New York yeah
then I couldn't get job I worked at a
waitress at Jackson Hole did you get any
work when you were I got off off off off
off off
Broadway did you ever try to do
commercials I did one commercial and and
it stops Big Boy Bob's Big Boy was that
fun
well I wasn't even the Bob's Big Boy
representative I was the the competition
it was pretty I thought it was pretty
impressive incredible would you go out
on audition for commercials and then not
get them and then you go Jesus Christ
this is this career side oh god well
auditioning for commercials is
ridiculous like you're at a party
you know and you're all having eating
hamburgers and drinking diet coke or
whatever and you're pretending that
you've met all of these people and did
you begin to lose faith in yourself I
didn't know I was taking classes with
Anthony apeson after once I graduated
didn't go to college were you afraid you
couldn't make a living oddly I was not
afraid I never had that fear I I really
enjoyed waitressing and I really enjoyed
the
play I it had nothing to really compare
it to so I had what when I got to work I
I was also 18. right so when you go out
to LA it's just it's it's a struggle at
first right because it was a little bit
I lived at my dad's I then uh was
telemarketing
really I had to borrow 100 bucks from my
friend for head shots right and uh then
I got a job three months after being out
here Malloy with my embiolic Malloy and
but Malloy didn't didn't last six six
episodes six episodes yeah isn't that
heartbreaking you probably thought your
career was over like you get I'm a
lawyer and you go this is my big break
I'm gonna be on network television I'm
alloy and then Malloy goes away I've
never had this this this you know train
of thought of oh I'm destroyed oh I
would be like I'd be like Oh I thought
this was it I thought it was gonna be a
network TV and I'd be famous and and
this would it would work well that's why
you do this and I do this yeah I know I
would not have to have some sort of
faith in yourself faith I know or Blind
Faith I don't know ignorance is that
when you did the movie this is this
movie is the bane of your existence you
did the you decided to do the movie
Leprechaun is this before friends it
obviously must be right leprechaun and
you hate that it it but but you have to
act you have to get into the door
somewhere I really thought I'd arrived
when I did
Davis the guy from Willow was in it
that's a big deal big deal yeah but you
cringe when you say you don't see it on
TV or you would never go back and watch
you know I watched it like eight years
ago with uh with our mutual friend
Justin Thoreau just for shits and
giggles this is why you were uh engaged
or dating dating at the very beginning
and he I was one of those things where
was I
tried to like get that thing out of the
remote out of his hand and there was
just no you mean he happened upon it
it's like no no no no this is happening
foreign